well as this unfolds Richard I wonder
what your thoughts are does it surprise
you and how strong do you think this
faction of the military is do you
believe they'll be able to to pull off a
coup it's easier to answer your first
question than the second it's not
totally surprising given how polarized
Turkish society has become how strained
relations have been and continue to be
between the military and mr. Diwan and
others in terms of the strength of this
faction their agenda and a million other
questions nobody at least on the outside
that I've seen has the has the answers
to that let me ask you then when you say
polarized I automatically think of what
I just witnessed in London 52 to 48 as
far as the split there what I feel like
we have here in the US which isn't
almost I think the most recent New York
Times poll says 40 percent for Clinton
40 percent for Trump is it that kind of
polarization in Turkey where you've got
almost a dead even split it's hard to
say because the electoral process itself
has been so much skewed and the military
doesn't stand if you will against or no
water or anybody else well you have
though a lot of indications of a society
that has multiple fault lines whether
it's between various Kurdish political
activists and the and the government or
between secularists and people who are
anything but secularists between left
traditional left and right a lot of that
personal animosity against mr. Irulan so
what you're seeing is simply a society
that's increasingly characterized by its
divisions I don't because I don't think
aligns itself up as a need one side
versus another side thing as you see in
situations like the United States say or
Britain Richard one of the national
security implications of this for the
United States well it's enormous Turkey
is one of those critical countries by
virtue of its geography that is central
in multiple for most recently obviously
in the Middle East Turkey what it does
and doesn't do has a tremendous impact
among other things what happens we said
the ISIS what happens in
in Syria it's also been the principal
conveyor belt in both directions in one
direction for recruits joining Isis and
the other direction for refugees heading
north into into Europe you've got all
those issues trick is obviously a member
of NATO so it's one of those countries
that probably doesn't get the attention
it deserves but what you're looking at
European issues Middle Eastern issues to
some extent even Eurasian issues turkey
turns out to be as history would suggest
them you know it's with the role of back
in Constantinople now Istanbul Turkey is
always been as been pivotal Richard as
my colleague here Matt Miller had
mentioned earlier in our coverage there
are conflicting reports about exactly
what's going on and as you know we're in
the early stages of this so that is not
unexpected but what we have been hearing
is that some of those who have decided
to take this action against the
government are blaming the government
saying it's corrupt and that it's not
doing enough to fight terrorism is that
the valid argument that they will use
for having taken this action emphasizing
a lot about the rule of law there are
all sorts of charges against their
launch family on on corruption there's
lots of criticism about what he's done
or hasn't done visa vie the Kurds look
but the real question will be does that
justify the fact that they're acting in
an extra democratic way just a question
simply who prevails if mr. Dewan
prevails the question then is what it's
retribution looked like what happens
within Turkey to this can become grounds
or justification for him to do further
cracks that crackdowns and further the
snapping of Turkish democracy if those
behind the coup were to win the issue
then is what is their agenda and there's
also a third possibility and either side
wins any time soon and you have some
prolong standoff which could lead to
quite a lot of domestic violence so this
year this could play out in lots of in
lots of ways I wonder you know Dan Moss
was just on set with us and he was
reminded of the August push in Russia
when Yeltsin and some hardliners tried
to overthrow Gorbachev's government that
- lasted I don't know two or three days
it turned out to be unsuccessful but it
just shows you Richard that a coup
doesn't always immediately yield results
it wouldn't surprise you I'm guessing to
see this thing last throughout the
weekend even throughout the next week it
wouldn't surprise me it could also be
resolved quickly I don't mean to deduct
your question but it would because a lot
of people may wait and see
no one wants to end up on the wrong side
of this so people may want to see which
way it seems to be tilting and then they
will rally around the bandwagon on the
side that seems likely to prevail this
makes it which makes it self fulfilling
the one thing we haven't talked about
also which i think is interesting is
what outsiders do what the United States
does what various European governments
do and at least so forth so far at least
you see an awful lot of wait-and-see
postures
I think Outsiders also want to get a
sense of how this is playing out before
they either come down and conditionally
embrace a coup or conditionally embrace
the government Richard is there a
possibility or even a danger that an
action like this may in bold in other
countries in the region other militaries
to do the same I doubt it you've already
had the Egyptian experience which and
police what the surface is not
dissimilar so there could be other
situations but these tend not to be
knock on or copycats what happens is you
have the political dynamics within each
country pretty much determines what what
happens this is not something that
people wake up and see on TV and say
let's do the same thing here it really
tends to be homegrown Richard give us a
sense then if the Obama administration
is having a National Security Council
meeting and this is on the top of the
agenda what is their main concern at
this point the president has reportedly
it is a big issue and I think the real
question again is uh to what extent do
they indicate where what their leanings
are to what extent they're holding back
they hold back and see how it unfolds
and so far at least they seem to be
adopting more the holding back strategy
rather than either siding with the
government or siding with those against
the government